je m'appelle Stéphane Loriot je
travaille au PNR Chevreuse dont
l'animation la communication
nous allons voir ce matin 4 plantes
seulement entre guillemets seulement 4
parmi les nombreuses qui sont bien bien
présentes donc la pariétaire la mauve
Sylvestre la prunelle sauvage et puis le
fameux Blandine
nous allons c'est parti
[Musique]
là en ce moment la pariétaire qui est
vivace de la même famille que l'ortie
même famille elle ne pique pas
évidemment en terme médicinales elle a
cette cette qualité d'être l'une des
meilleures plantes contre les cystites
et en termes de saveurs là avant
floraison en mélange en salade tout à
fait tout à fait tout à fait intéressant
[Musique]
je vous présente très volontiers la môme
et Sylvestre Malva sylvestris elle est
vraiment vraiment sa brousse elle est
douce laxative expectorante et en soupe
elle est vraiment intéressante
évidemment et puis une recette avec de
la mauve de la menthe sauvage et une
seule tomate comme exhaustors du goût là
vous avez un fricassé en 15 minutes tout
à fait savoureux et ça contient du
mucilage c'est bon pour les bons donc en
ce moment nous observons ces plantes
sauvages qui se refont des cycles
elles vont bien s'en sortir pendant
cette mutation climatique qui va durer
une éternam nos forêts souffrent nos
plantes cultivées souffrent nos plantes
sauvages ont cette capacité au coeur de
l'été et de se cacher d'un députer à
leur force pour reprendre pendant cet
automne de plus en plus chaud
[Musique]
alors nous avons ici la prunelle sauvage
prunus et Spinoza en cette fin octobre
les prunelles sont savoureuses
évidemment très peu amer le fruit est de
plus en plus sucré de moins en moins
amer de moins en moins astringents et
puis pour autant les préparations
froides ou chaudes sont vraiment
vraiment succulentes une recette
extrêmement simple vous les dénoyauter
avec le pouce et l'index ce n'est pas ce
n'est pas le bout du monde vous les
couvrez d'eau un peu de miel du piment
au bout d'un quart d'heure vous avez un
coulis que vous avez écrasé avec un
presse-purée et là vous avez un coulis
tiède ou froid que vous utilisez avec
des yaourts avec du chèvre frais sur un
toast
[Musique]
cette année ne pas parler de la récolte
de glandes chêne c'est impossible j'ai
rarement vu autant de glands au sol
autant de chaînes qui produisent autant
de ce fruit vraiment savoureux en terme
de protéine de protéines c'est un record
bien au-delà de nos fameuses lentilles
par exemple et puis le verbe glander
vient de là je n'ai rien fait de l'année
je me contente de les ramasser par
contre pour la préparation vous glandez
beaucoup moins il faut les écorcer il
faut les faire bouillir à trois os pour
éliminer le tanin ça se rapprocherait de
la châtaigne ou de la noix un mélange
des deux
[Musique]
c'est gratuit c'est de la filière courte
ce sont des aliments ce sont des plantes
qui correspondent en l'occurrence
alimentaire selon ou selon les saisons
ça c'est une première chose mais
globalement elles sont toutes et
s'éprouvées depuis longtemps deux à
trois fois plus nourrissantes que nous
plantes cultivées dis moi dans l'année
vous pouvez vraiment facilement trouver
de quoi vous nourrir avec des plantes de
proximité
[Musique]